an actress of depth and beauty Jennifer
Lopez
you have heard the five nominated songs
and now it is time to review them once
more in time for the respective
composers and lyricists to call up the
last line of the oscar-winning song from
1954 three coins in the fountain make it
mine make it mine make it mine from
Armageddon I don't want to miss a thing
music and lyric by Diane Warren from
quest for Camelot the prayer music by
Carole Bayer Sager and David Foster
lyric by Carole Bayer Sager David Foster
Tony Ramos and Alberto testa from The
Horse Whisperer a soft place to fall
music and lyric by Allison Moore and
glowin from babe pig in the city that'll
do music and lyric by Randy Newman
from the Prince of Egypt when you
believe music and lyrics by Stephen
Schwartz and the Oscar goes to Stephen
Schwartz for when you believe from the
Prince of Egypt Stephen Schwartz is very
sorry that he cannot be here he's in
rehearsals for a show in New York but he
wishes to express his gratitude to the
members of the Academy thank you